acarrear las pertenencias en un carrito
para huir del narcotráfico Esa es la
situación que padecen los vecinos de la
ciudad santafesina de Rosario la
creciente violencia entre bandas
criminales ha escalado en los últimos
días transformándose en una preocupación
por el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
he dispuesto el refuerzo de las fuerzas
federales hasta alcanzar en esta etapa
los 1.400 efectivos disponibles para la
ciudad de Rosario Vamos a ponerle fin a
la violencia criminal de sicarios
mercaderes de la muerte
ninguna organización criminal
ninguna real mafiosa puede contra la
fuerza de un pueblo Unido y en defensa
de su tierra y de su vida en comunidad
esto sucede días después de que el
ministro de seguridad de la nación
Aníbal Fernández reconociera que los
narcotraficantes han ganado Rosario pero
el desencadenante fue el asesinato de
Máximo Jerez un niño de 11 años
asesinado a tiros tras quedar en el
medio de un enfrentamiento armado entre
bandas hecho que también dejó a tres
menores heridos chao les digo que esto
hace por dos meses por tres meses
después se van a olvidar de nosotros y
Nosotros igual
volvemos de vuelta víctima de las drogas
porque son búnker que están acá un
montón este lunes los vecinos tomaron
justicia por mano propia si bien la
policía arrestó al asesino debió
protegerlo una turba que desvalijó su
casa y la demolió Nosotros sí tenemos
miedo tenemos miedo pero tenemos que
seguir adelante ya nos metimos acá y
tenemos que seguir y rompe todo esto
para que se nos lleva a todos los chicos
los jóvenes los adolescentes Rosario
tiene una de las tasas de homicidios más
altas de Argentina en la icónica ciudad
santafesina es frecuente los combates
entre bandas narcotraficantes que se
cobran la vida de civiles inocentes